Let us now revisit the subject
of expectations and develop an
important linearity property
for the case where we're
dealing with multiple
random variables.
We already have a linearity
property.
If we have a linear function of
a single random variable,
then expectations behave
in a linear fashion.
But now, if we have multiple
random variables, we have this
additional property.
The expected value of the sum
of two random variables is
equal to the sum of their
expectations.
Let us go through the derivation
of this very
important fact because it is a
nice exercise in applying the
expected value rule and
also manipulating
PMFs and joint PMFs.
We're dealing with the expected
value of a function
of two random variables.
Which function?
If we write it this way, we are
dealing with the function
g, which is just the sum
of its two entries.
So now we can continue with
the application of the
expected value rule.
And we obtain the sum over
all possible x, y pairs.
Here, we need to write
to g of x,y.
But in our case, the function
we're dealing with
is just x plus y.
And then we weigh, according
to the entries
of the joint PMF.
So this is just an application
of the expected value rule to
this particular function.
Now let us take this sum and
break it into two pieces--
one involving only the x-term,
and another piece involving
only the y-term.
Now, if we look at this
double summation, look
at the inner sum.
It's a sum over y's.
While we're adding over y's, the
value of x remains fixed.
So x is a constant, as far
as the sum is concerned.
So x can be pulled outside
this summation.
Let us just continue with this
term, the first one, and see
that a simplification happens.
This quantity here is the sum
of the probabilities of the
different y's that can go
together with a particular x.
So it is just equal to
the probability or
that particular x.
It's the marginal PMF.
If we carry out a similar step
for the second term, we will
obtain the sum over y's.
It's just a symmetrical
argument.
And at this point we recognize
that what we have in front of
us is just the expected value of
X, this is the first term,
plus the expected value of
Y. So this completes the
derivation of this important
linearity property.
Of course, we proved the
linearity property for the
case of the sum of two
random variables.
But you can proceed in a similar
way, or maybe use
induction, and one can easily
establish, by following the
same kind of argument, that we
have a linearity property when
we add any finite number
of random variables.
The expected value of
a sum is the sum of
the expected values.
Just for a little bit of
practice, if, for example,
we're dealing with this
expression, the expected value
of that expression would be the
expected value of 2X plus
the expected value of 3Y minus
the expected value of Z. And
then, using the linearity
property for linear functions
of a single random variable, we
can pull the constants out
of the expectations.
And this would be twice the
expected value of X plus 3
times the expected value of Y
minus the expected value of Z.
What we will do next is to use
the linearity property of
expectations to solve a problem
that would otherwise
be quite difficult.
We will use the linearity
property to find the mean of a
binomial random variable.
Let X be a binomial random
variable with
parameters n and p.
And we can interpret X as the
number of successes in n
independent trials where each
one of the trials has a
probability p of resulting
in a success.
Well, we know the PMF
of a binomial.
And we can use the definition of
expectation to obtain this
expression.
This is just the PMF
of the binomial.
And therefore, what we have here
is the usual definition
of the expected value.
Now, if you look at this sum,
it appears quite formidable.
And it would be quite
hard to evaluate it.
Instead, we're going to use
a very useful trick.
We will employ what we have
called indicator variables.
So let's define a random
variable Xi, which is a one if
the ith trial is a success,
and zero otherwise.
Now if we want to count
successes, what we want to
count is how many of the
Xi's are equal to 1.
So if we add the Xi's, this will
have a contribution of 1
from each one of
the successes.
So when you add them
up, you obtain the
total number of successes.
So we have expressed a random
variable as a sum of much
simpler random variables.
So at this point, we can now use
linearity of expectations
to write that the expected
value of X will be the
expected value of X1 plus
all the way to the
expected value of Xn.
Now what is the expected
value of X1?
It is a Bernoulli random
variable that takes the value
1 with probability p and takes
the value of 0 with
probability 1 minus p.
The expected value of this
random variable is p.
And similarly, for each one of
these terms in the summation.
And so the final end result
is equal to n times p.
This answer, of course, makes
also intuitive sense.
If we have to p equal to 1/2,
and we toss a coin 100 times,
the expected number, or the
average number, of heads we
expect to see will be 1/2 half
times 100, which is 50.
The higher p is, the more
successes we expect to see.
And of course, if we double
n, we expect to see
twice as many successes.
So this is an illustration of
the power of breaking up
problems into simpler pieces
that are easier to analyze.
And the linearity of
expectations is one more tool
that we have in our hands
for breaking up perhaps
complicated random variables
into simpler ones and then
analyzing them separately.